dans ce quartier populaire d'abidjan un
collège transformé en centre
d'inscription électorale de futurs
électeurs
parmi eux certains voteront pour la
première fois en octobre
j'aimerais à tous plus voter parce que
ça va me libérer les tuyaux du moi même
et à lester parce que quand tu es quand
un citoyen de ton pays et que t'y pas
que si fort du participant à tous et qui
sait pas dans ton pays tu t'es s'en
libérer la raison pour laquelle c'est
matt et messieurs les vnf à la roma
comme c'est le cas dans les onze mille
centres d'enrôlement que compte la côte
d'ivoire cet établissement n'atteint pas
ses objectifs
seulement 260 inscrits en huit jours
dont 80% de nouveaux majeurs maintenant
on prend le cas des nomades
quand il arrive à point le formulaire
les informations sur le formulaire
elle recueille ça sur la tablette après
ça evard plat peser vu la photo après la
photo elle passe aux emplois les douze
ans président a dit l'édile doit plus de
200 index voilà après ça est passé
maintenant
après les en pointe c'est la signature
du récurrent pour la sénatrice du
récurrent elle vérifie bien que les
informations sont exactes
avant l'enregistrement autre problème
plus de la moitié des candidats à
l'inscription ne dispose pas des
documents nécessaires certains déplorent
un manque d'implication des jeunes au
nom de moi mesdames et qu'elle même âge
que mon réseau peu d'engouement pas
saine d'esprit et je sens qu'ils sont
pas motivés par leur le manque de
nouveautés
je ne sais pas mais il ya tant que
les hommages ne soient pas nombreux
lamine faye le rôle de la commission
électorale indépendante vise cinq
millions de nouvelles inscriptions sur
les listes électorales
objectif 11 millions de votants sur 25
millions d'habitants au total
j'essaie d'expliquer à tout le monde que
la politique l affaire de tous et
s'inscrire sur une liste électorale
c'est de jouer son rôle citoyenne en
côte d'ivoire le vote n'étant pas
obligatoire
ça n'intéresse pas certaines personnes
et surtout les jeux ce qu'elle disait
souvent c'est la sphère des vieux dans
un pays où 70 7% de la population a
moins de 35 ans la mobilisation des
nouveaux votants un enjeu dont se saisit
le monde politique
le f pays le parti de l'ex président
laurent gbagbo par exemple après dix
années de boycott des élections
ce parti d'opposition voilà son possible
retour dans le jeu électoral avec
quelques 400 mille nouveaux inscrits
soit seulement 6 % de l'objectif
escompté
la commission envisage de prolonger les
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
qui doivent s'achever le 24 juin
[Musique]